We have seen so far an example
of a probability law on a
discrete and finite sample space
as well as an example
with an infinite and continuous
sample space.
Let us now look at an example
involving a discrete but
infinite sample space.
We carry out an experiment whose
outcome is an arbitrary
positive integer.
As an example of such an
experiment, suppose that we
keep tossing a coin and the
outcome is the number of
tosses until we observe heads
for the first time.
The first heads might appear
in the first toss or the
second or the third,
and so on.
So in this example, any positive
integer is possible.
And so our sample space
is infinite.
Let us not specify a
probability law.
A probability law should
determine the probability of
every event, of every subset
of the sample space.
That is, the probability
of every
set of positive integers.
But instead I will just tell you
the probability of events
that contain a single element.
I'm going to tell you that there
is probability 1 over 2
to the n that the outcome
is equal to n.
Is this good enough?
Is this information enough to
determine the probability of
any subset?
Before we look into that
question, let us first do a
quick sanity check to see
whether these numbers that we
are given look like legitimate
probabilities.
Do they add to 1?
Let's do a quick check.
So the sum over all the possible
values of n of the
probabilities that we're given,
which is an infinite
sum starting from 1, all the way
up to infinity, of 1 over
2 to the n, is equal
to the following.
First we take out a factor of
1/2 from all of these terms,
which reduces the exponent
from n to n minus 1.
This is the same as running
the sum from n equals 0 to
infinity of 1/2 and to the n.
And now we have a usual infinite
geometric series and
we have a formula for this.
The geometric series has a value
of 1 over 1 minus the
number whose power we're
taking, which is 1/2.
And after we do the arithmetic,
this turns out to
be equal to 1.
So indeed, it appears that we
have the basic elements of
what it would take to have a
legitimate probability law.
But now let us look into how
we might calculate the
probability of some
general event.
For example, the probability
that the outcome is even.
We proceed as follows.
The probability that the outcome
is even, this is the
probability of an infinite
set that consists of
all the even integers.
We can write this set as the
union of lots of little sets
that contain a single
element each.
So it's the set containing the
number 2, the set containing
the number 4, the set
containing the
number 6, and so on.
At this point we notice that
we're talking about the
probability of a union of sets
and these sets are disjoint
because they contain
different elements.
So we can use an additivity
property and say that this is
the probability of obtaining a
2, plus the probability of
obtaining a 4, plus
the probability of
obtaining a 6 and so on.
If you're curious about doing
this calculation and actually
obtaining a numerical answer,
you would proceed as follows.
You notice that this is 1 over
2 to the second power plus 1
over 2 to the fourth power plus
1 over 2 to the sixth
power and so on.
Now you factor out a factor of
1/4 and what you're left is 1
plus 1 over 2 to the second
power, which is 1/4, plus 1
over 2 to the fourth power,
which is the same as 1/4 to
the second power and so on.
And now we have 1/4 times the
infinite sum of a geometric
series, which gives us
1 over 1 minus 1/4.
And after you do the algebra you
obtain a numerical answer,
which is equal to 1/3.
But leaving the details of the
calculation aside, the more
important question I want to
address is the following.
Is this calculation correct?
We seem to have used
an additivity
property at this point.
But the additivity properties
that we have in our hands at
this point only talk about
disjoint unions of finitely
many subsets.
Our initial axiom talked about
a disjoint union of two
subsets and then later on we
established a similar property
for a disjoint union of
finitely many subsets.
But here we're talking
about the union of
infinitely many subsets.
So this step here is not really
allowed by what we have
in our hands.
On the other hand, we would like
our theory to allow this
kind of calculation.
The way out of this dilemma is
to introduce an additional
axiom that will indeed allow
this kind of calculation.
The axiom that we introduce
is the following.
If we have an infinite sequence
of disjoint events,
as for example in
this picture.
We have our sample space.
We have a first event, A1.
We have a second event, A2.
The third event, A3.
And so we keep continuing and
we have an infinite sequence
of such events.
Then the probability of the
union of these events, of
these infinitely many events, is
the sum of their individual
probabilities.
The key word here is
the word sequence.
Namely, these events, these sets
that we're dealing with,
can be arranged so that we can
talk about the first event,
A1, the second event, A2, the
third one, A3, and so on.
To appreciate the issue that
arises here and to see why the
word sequence is so important,
let us consider the following
calculation.
Our sample space is
the unit square.
And we consider a model where
the probability of a set is
its area, as in the examples
that we considered earlier.
Let us now look at the
probability of the overall
sample space.
Our sample space is the unit
square and the unit square can
be thought of as the union of
various sets that consist of
single points.
So it's the union of subsets
with one element each.
And it's a union taken
over all the
points in the unit square.
Then we think about
additivity.
We observe that these subsets
are disjoint.
If we're considering different
points, then we get disjoint
single element sets.
And then an additivity property
would tells us that
the probability of these
union is the sum of the
probabilities of the different
single element subsets.
Now, as we discussed before,
single element subsets have 0
probability.
So we have a sum of lots of 0s
and the sum of 0s should be
equal to 0.
On the other hand, by the
probability axioms, the
probability of the entire
sample space
should be equal to 1.
And so we have established
that 1 is equal to 0.
This looks like a paradox.
Is it?
The catch is that there is
nothing in the axioms we have
introduced so far or the
properties we have established
that would justify this step.
So this step here
is questionable.
You might argue that the unit
square is the union of
disjoint single element sets,
which is the case that we have
in additivity axioms.
But the additivity axiom only
applies when we have a
sequence of events.
And this is not what
we have here.
This is not a union
of a sequence of
single element sets.
In fact, there is no way that
the elements of the unit
square can be arranged
in a sequence.
The unit square is said to
be an uncountable set.
This is a deep and fundamental
mathematical fact.
What it essentially says is that
there are two kinds of
infinite sets.
Discrete ones or in formal
terminology countable.
These are sets whose elements
can be arranged in a sequence,
like the integers.
And also uncountable sets, such
as the unit square or the
real line, whose elements
cannot be
arranged in a sequence.
If you're curious, you can
find the proof of this
important fact in the
supplementary materials that
we are providing.
After all these discussion, you
may now have legitimate
suspicions about the models
we have been looking at.
Is area a legitimate
probability law?
Does it even satisfy countable
additivity?
This question takes us into deep
waters and has to do with
a deep subfield of mathematics
called Measure Theory.
Fortunately, it turns out
that all is well.
Area is a legitimate
probability law.
It does indeed satisfy the
countable additivity axiom as
long as we only deal with nice
subsets of the unit square.
Fortunately, the subsets that
arise in whatever we do in
this course will be "nice".
Subsets that are not nice are
quite pathological and we will
not encounter them.
At this stage we are not in a
position to say anything more
that would be meaningful about
these issues because they're
quite complicated and
mathematically deep.
We can only say that there are
some serious mathematical
subtleties.
But fortunately, they
can all be overcome
in a rigorous manner.
And for the rest of this class,
you can just forget
about these subtle issues.